[Music]
hi my name is Fred Chung part of Android
developer relations today we're going to
talk about Bluetooth Low Energy in
Android 4.3 we are adding built-in
platform support for Bluetooth le the
new Nexus 7 and the Nexus 4 are the
first two Nexus devices that are going
to be Bluetooth smart ready making them
capable of communicating with the many
Bluetooth smart peripherals on the
market today I'm going to do a sample
app walkthrough today but before doing
that I'd like to walk you through some
technical concept of Bluetooth Low
Energy so that you can make sense out of
the API objects as this name implies
Bluetooth Low Energy uses less energy as
compared with Bluetooth classic it is
not uncommon to have Bluetooth Low
Energy devices that last for weeks if
not years before needing to recharge or
replacing the battery the protocol
itself is optimized for a small burst of
data exchange which is ideal for
applications such as sensors remote
controllers so on and so forth in
contrast Bluetooth classic quite often
is involved in high bandwidth
applications such as audio streaming now
let's have a look at how information is
structured in ble applications ble is
based on a specification called general
attribute profile or get it governs
sending and receiving of short pieces of
data known as attributes the Android app
can be either it get client or a get
server depending on the application the
get server can support a collection of
services you can think of services as
different features offered by the device
each service is uniquely identified by a
you a reference about by your
application under each service there
could be a collection of characteristics
which you can perform read or write
operations depending on the btle profile
you're working with to put things in
perspective let's have a look at the
heart rate measurement profile which is
one of the standard profiles
the heart rate sensor is the get server
the Android app in this diagram is the
GATT client the get server hosted on the
heart rate sensor device offer a number
of services under the service there's a
collection of get characteristics
there's one for providing heart rate
measurement which you can receive
notification on when that indicates the
location of the sensor which you can
read from now that we have some basic
understanding on Bluetooth Tenergy
technology let's have a look at some
code let's first take a look at the
Android manifest there's a new feature
called Android Hardware dot Bluetooth le
you declare it if your application is
would only work on devices that has that
feature you can omit it if your
application would work on a device
without that feature so that you can
optionally make disable the Bluetooth
Low Energy features within your app now
the debugging session is up I'm gonna go
ahead and click scan so I've put some
breakpoints here what is trying to do is
to call a start le scan method call and
as you can see in the API documentation
a lot of a lot of the ble operation
methods are asynchronous in nature you
have to specify a callback such that
when interesting events happen in this
case when devices are discover the
callback methods are involved so I'm
going to let this breakpoint go as you
can see in the app it's able to find a
couple of devices let's go ahead and
click on heart rate sensor which
corresponds to the test kit that I'm
trying to test with so let's go ahead
and click on it now it brings you to
another activity which is bound to a
background service and I've put a
breakpoint in a service what it's trying
to do is to connect to the GATT server
that's hosted on this device by invoking
this method call connected yet just like
the previous example since all api's
that have
with me I'll use our asynchronous in
nature you have to pass in another
callback here now that we've connected
to the GATT server is trying to invoke
this call this method called discover
services by trying to discover the
available guest services hosted on this
device let's go ahead and release the
breakpoint and now the callback on
services discovered is invoked meaning I
have found the app has found the
services that are available on the
device the apps going to iterate through
the the collection of services found and
display on the UI as seen here since
this is a heart rate sensor we're gonna
do some heart rate measurement let's go
ahead and locate the heart rate service
expand it and you see heart rate
measurement characteristic let's go
ahead and click on it what happens is
that since it knows that the
characteristic supports notification it
tries to enable the notification so
let's go ahead and release this
breakpoint now as soon as it begins
getting heart rate updates reading
you'll get this car back on
characteristic change indicating that
indicating that you are receiving a
notification so we're going to go ahead
and release the breakpoint as you can
see on the screen here we are receiving
heart rate measurement readings in this
in this very very tiny text I don't know
if you can see it but it's updating with
heart rate measurement notifications
receiving from the peripherals now I
want to illustrate a very important
point and that is whenever you are done
with a particular Bluetooth le
connection with the peripheral you
should really call this closed method so
that the stack can do its cleanup
properly that's it for the walkthrough
if you want to learn more do check out
the Bluetooth Low Energy developer guide
on the Android comm thank you for
watching